[Music]
will he get all high falutin
when he sits down with vladimir
this week president biden's meeting with
russian president
vladimir putin and is expected to be
frostier than the icing on nicole
wallace's morning daiquiri
but as far as time mag is concerned
joe's gonna crush it
now compare that to this 2018 cover
where they morphed trump into putin
into the same person it's either side by
side
producers good job what a difference
bias can make
speaking of trump he's still gracious as
ever wishing biden well in an
email quote good luck to biden and
dealing with president putin don't fall
asleep during the meeting
and please give him my warmest regards
that's more exciting than any of these
meetings anyway it is great advice
joe should also remind himself
beforehand that he's president
because he tends to forget though who
knows if joe will be up to the task
considering how his press conference at
the g7 summit went on sunday
first he confused syria with libya
we could work together with russia for
example
uh in uh in libya they have also
bitten off some real problems they're
going to have trouble chewing on
for example the rebuilding of
of syria of uh of libya
i'm hopeful that we can find an
accommodation
that where we can save the lives of
people in for example
in uh in libya oh geez
that's like confusing canada with clams
[Laughter]
he also joked about his handlers
controlling the number of questions he
takes
and from who though it didn't seem like
he wanted to answer uh
i'm sorry i'm gonna get in trouble with
staff i don't do this the right way
jennifer jacob bloomberg
i'm gonna get in trouble with my pr my
staff yeah go ahead but i bring pretend
that
you didn't answer you you kept in place
some trump-era steel and aluminum
sanctions
and i wanted to ask you when you're
having these conversations
with european allies who are very
concerned about these sanctions
how do you justify that and what are
your plans 120 days
give me a break need time
that's a great darth vader
it's been 145 days actually i got a
chill
i got a chill up my spine
oh boy but that's only the third most
awkward moment from the summit
after this picture look at that
creepiest set of chess pieces i've ever
seen
then there was the bump fest
[Music]
fun fact that's how eels have sex
[Applause]
but it's like jeff zucker said to
jeffrey tubin you shouldn't do that on
camera
all right mackie what do you make of
this whole thing uh i'm not really sure
what they're going with
for with this whole joe biden aviator
sunglasses look
i don't know who that's fooling because
if he's if he's a pilot i think he's
well past the faa's retirement
[Laughter]
people are saying that biden reminds
them of franklin roosevelt and that's
true it's just that
it's more like the roosevelt from 1946
right
yes on the way down kind of reminds me
of eleanor i don't know cat
um is this show you that it's just more
theater than it
like i finally realized how much of this
is just
theater it took me it took it took trump
to kind of shake the box
for me to see that it's this is just a
bunch of
this is just a waste of time am i wrong
no
you're not wrong at all all right next
question
well i just trump watching the press
conference people on the left talk about
it they're like
that was so crazy that was so what like
as if they're talking to people you know
trump supporters if they don't know that
transfers all knew that it was you know
crazy but they just were into that
they liked it but i wish that people on
the left could be
more honest about what's happening now
they're saying well now things are back
to normal things are normal
it's traditional that's not normal you
can't watch one of those and say
that that's anything close to normal
presidents normally like
know where they are confidently like
at a minimum and then can even go the
extra mile in being able to competently
answer questions
that's not happening we're not seeing
that acknowledgement from anybody
but at least he's not tweeting and
that's the most important thing
i don't think he could no yeah that's
true that's true
that's true and who cares joey who cares
if the president
thinks libya is syria and syria is libya
he's so much nicer
than trump you know we've gone through
some presidents they kind of just wanted
to bomb them all and go to war with all
of them anyways
yeah i don't know that it matters i
don't expect them to understand that but
it's a little bit in my crawl right now
number one i really hope we just find
out he's a big pothead and he's been
high for a few years
because at least at that point i
understand it and i'm not concerned
about the man's health because i don't
know that he's going to make it i really
don't i mean and i hate to say that but
here's let me let me just
you can turn a punk-ass 18 year old into
a marine
with honor courage and commitment in 90
days
all right most rehab facilities that
take you off whatever has control
over your life are 30 to 60 days
and let me tell you something greg i
went from having the my legs
removed from my body to ping standing up
in 110 days i know because i took a
picture
but in 120 days he can't decide what he
thinks about the policies he got elected
attacking he should do about him
and he's going to get mad at you and
talk to you all real weird about it
who are you intimidating dude i could
like tap you on the forehead and hit a
reset button
there's nothing intimidating going on
there like jill maybe i don't know but
but i mean well it just makes me mad
it's also he's been there for
40 50 years so what is 120 days to
50 years so america reports
is one to three p.m in the afternoon
shameless plug that nice plug
we have caught i think more biting news
conferences than
any other show on the network yeah
because it's that hour let me just tell
you it would be a good thing if viewers
fell asleep
watching them because they'd probably
leave the channel on yes but i think
they just leave when it when it happens
but
we've noticed some trends with the
question taking with biden you'll notice
and you just showed it there he picks up
the folder at the end he's the president
he's got somebody to pick up his folder
for him
right but he picks it up and he's got
this move where if he doesn't
have planned questions that he's going
to take
but he kind of wants to show he'll field
one or two he picks up the folder he
kind of motions
he's walking away he's done somebody
shouts a question that he wants to grab
he'll grab it he'll take it one maybe
and then he says his staff you'll get
into trouble with his staff
um the the fist bumping boggles me the
the arms
are they all vaccinated adults yeah
leaders
of their country they're so small
everybody just appears so small
when they do that stuff and they look
like they're having fun
they're not allowed to have fun be sad
for whatever the rest of their lives are
like
morris johnson did a whole move did you
see kind of went out to the left and
then back with the whole body like
he's the only one that's actually he's
lunging yeah yeah
all right enough of that terrible video
i wonder if he's saying boo every time
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else